a diferencia de otras democracias en
eeuu es tradicional que los partidos
políticos celebren elecciones internas
para elegir a sus candidatos a este
sistema lo llaman elecciones primarias y
aunque a priori suene muy bonito es muy
complicado y en ocasiones injustos hoy
vamos a explicarte cómo funciona y lo
vamos a hacer de la mano de todo un
experto will fox es un youtuber político
su canal se llama political yanqui y
está especializado en política americana
hola soy will de político john keane soy
americano pero vivo en europa y me hace
mucha gracia cuando los europeos me
hacéis siempre las mismas preguntas qué
[ __ ] pasa a los americanos porque votan
santoro trump es verdad que han estado
finos todos vais con pistola por la
calle porque no te de salir al publicar
esperas porque los policías van
disparando a la gente por ahí estás a
favor de la guerra
y mi favorito de todas con descubren que
eso de texas me dice que entonces eres
un cable no no
bueno tengo no hay otra pregunta que me
suelen hacer y la pregunta es cómo
funcionan las elecciones primarias en
eeuu
las primarias son las elecciones
internas de los dos grandes partidos de
los estados unidos el partido demócrata
que es de izquierdas aunque su color sea
azul y el partido republicano que es de
la derecha aunque su color sea del rojo
elegir a su candidato por presidente se
celebra en cada uno de los 50 estados
tú puedes ir votar y después por
supuesto protestar porque el candidato
al que has elegido te ha decepcionado
parece muy fácil verdad bueno en
realidad es un poco más complicado
porque en realidad no votas a un
candidato sino a unos delegados pero
will que son los delegados ahora os
cuento los delegados son los que votarán
por un candidato y en la convención
nacional del partido que se celebran en
verano nada más que terminan las
primarias las convenciones nacionales
son el evento en el que los partidos
nacionales los partidos políticos
seleccionan a sus candidatos formalmente
por ejemplo sin tono trump consigue el
50% de los votos de texas en teoría
tendrá 50 delegados que voten por él en
la convención nacional republicana así
que el que tiene más delegados gana la
convención y se presenta a las
elecciones presidenciales que se
celebran en noviembre pero espera un
momento que no es tan sencillo
resulta que el partido demócrata existe
una cosa que se llama su delegado el
superdelegado un superdelegado es una
persona que pertenece a la élite del
partido demócrata a la que se le permite
votar a quien quiera en la convención es
decir si hay un delegado de canjes que
le eligen para que vote a lo diferente
durante las elecciones primarias está
obligado a votar a hillary clinton en la
convención sin embargo si esa misma
persona fuera un superdelegado podría
votar por organizar el solo por quien
quisiera o sea que podría darse el caso
en que un candidato tiene más votos pero
pierde la convención porque los
superdelegados deciden apoyar al
contrario es una locura verdad
los partidarios de bernie sanders
quieren abolir la figura de los
superdelegados en el partido demócrata
bueno así es como funciona la política
de los eeuu pero ahora os explico por
qué ocurre decimos que tenemos primarias
para simplificar pero en realidad
algunos estados que tienen primarias y
hay otros estados que tienen algo que se
llama cross en español lo pronunciamos
como caucus y que es un cocker
imagínate que eres americano y que vas a
votar a realizarse en algo que es del
partido demócrata en iowa llegas a una
habitación muy grande donde te esperan
otros miembros de tu comunidad ahí te
sientas en una mesa donde hay otros
miembros de tu comunidad que apoyan a tu
candidato discutir juntos durante unos
30 minutos y si en algún momento tienes
cambia de idea puedes ir a la mesa de
jericó iter y por apoyar a hillary
cliente al final cuando ya no queda
nadie discutiendo se cuentan los votos
de cada mesa y los delegados se asignan
de forma proporcional
pero espera porque todavía hay más los
delegados de los jueces de las primarias
no van directamente a la convención
nacional normalmente se les filtra en
otras condiciones más pequeñas al nivel
local de distrito o de estado
por eso los partidarios del grupo en
tenida y permisado les están discutiendo
todo el día es una chapuza de sistema
verdad en water familia culta pues ahora
os voy a algo más que iba a terminar de
romper los esquemas en realidad casi
nadie y participa en las primarias en el
2012 sólo 16% de los americanos eligió a
sus candidatos
y en estas elecciones sólo el 20 por
ciento de la población de los votantes
se ha animado a meter su pataleta o sea
cuando decís que los americanos estamos
locos a votar por votar a donald trump
pensar que solo le habrán votado 12 o 13
millones de personas y que esto solo es
el 42 por ciento de los votos de los
republicanos en la primaria republicana
o sea que ni siquiera la mayoría de los
conservadores le ha dicho de otra forma
menos del 4 por ciento de la población
americano ha votado a tono throne en
esta elección en esta primaria sin
embargo todos los americanos tendremos
que decidir si nos gusta o no durante
las elecciones de noviembre bienvenidos
a la política americana
y si os apetece aprender más de la
política de los eeuu o simplemente si
quieres mejorar vuestro inglés pues por
favor visitarme en mi canal político
john keynes hacer clic aquí en político
jon kim os encontraréis un montón de
vídeos sobre la política y la historia
adoro